there's something weird going on with
this it's the formula to find the volume
of a sphere in any Dimension this is
recursive so to find the volume of a
five-dimensional sphere Set n is equal
to five and it would be 2 pi r squared
over 5 times the volume of the
three-dimensional sphere
so here's a list of the formulas for
spheres in each Dimension up to 10. if
we set the radius to 1 for each of them
we get a number for the volume and can
compare here's a plot of Dimension
versus sphere volume it increases
initially but then peaks in The Fifth
Dimension it then drops off and tends
towards zero an infinite dimensional
sphere would have a volume of zero and a
5D sphere has the greatest volume of all
so I guess that's where the party's at